6 26 on your monday morning getting in
touch with the right people so you can
tell them what's driving you crazy a lot
of the emails we get it here are
trying to fix a neighborhood problem
like andrew up in north las vegas he
says i live close to the intersection of
azure and stats that's
south of centennial parkway between losi
road and pecos he says it's marked as a
25 mile per hour zone but most drivers
go through at 45 or more
it's supposed to be a two-way stop for
azure but he says a lot of drivers blow
through the stop sign
or figure that stats needs to stop as
well but that's not the case he says
we've had multiple accidents
including one fatal he adds i've looked
high
and low but i can't figure out how to
petition for
better speed limit signage or for a
four-way
stop to hopefully prevent more
fatalities in the future well here's the
deal andrew the intersection of azure
and stats
is in north las vegas ward 4 that is
served by councilman richard churchill
it's also served by county commission
district b
chairwoman marilyn kirkpatrick i'm going
to forward your concerns on to them
but i hope you do it on your own as well
in fact anybody you can look up your
elected representatives
they're usually the best place to start
speaking up about a problem all of our
reports are online at 8newsnow.com you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com